well as the school year comes to an end
for CCSD a teacher receiving quite the
thank you from the community a news hour
reporter Brian will capturing this
special moment at Von tobel Middle
School in the Northeast Valley
it's absolutely amazing I'm Blown Away
Jennifer Weddington has been giving her
students the keys to success for more
than 30 years and on Monday she got a
pair of keys to a brand new Kia Soul
for health as well too in the past which
a lot of people would have taken a lot
of time off and she chose to come to
work every day and she would show up for
the kids because she said kids are the
most important thing for me at this
point Jim Marsh Kia along with silver
state Schools Credit Union gifted the
car to acknowledge all her selfish work
at Van tobel Middle School scatter kills
with silver state says it's the least
they can do for those that do so much
for children there's nothing better than
to do this uh you know and give back and
and so uh you know we're always looking
forward to anything that we can do to
you know to give back to especially the
people that we serve every day
Weddington worked tirelessly alongside
her fellow teachers to achieve the
highest map growth the school has seen
in years it's a show of appreciation
that has isn't set in yet it makes a lot
of like what you do that goes unnoticed
when you are noticed you're like okay
maybe you know people do see what we do
every day